percent literally means per hundred
that's where the word comes from sent
from sense or century or any of those
words mean 100 so if someone tells you
seven per cent and I'm separating the
word so it makes a little more sense
they're always saying seven per hundred
this is the same thing as seven per
hundred which is the same thing as a
fraction as seven / 7 / hundred with
that out of the way let's see if we can
write if we can write zero point six
zero one as a as a percentage
well we essentially want to write it as
something over 100 so you could view it
as I'll just rewrite this part right
over here you could write it as zero
point six zero one over one this is
obviously the same quantity you divide
anything by one you're still going to
get that same anything and I'm going to
multiply it by I'm going to multiply it
by 100 over 100 obviously this won't
change the value this is just one here
but what this does is it'll give us a
fraction in term with the denominator
being a hundred so the denominator if I
multiply if I multiply these two
characters right over here in the
denominator the denominator of our
product is going to be 100
if I multiply point zero six zero one
times 100 what am I going to get well
every time I multiply it by a multiple
of ten or every time I multiply it by
ten I'm going to shift the decimal over
to the right once so if I multiply it by
ten I'd get six point zero one and if I
multiply it by ten again or if I
multiply it by 100 I'm going to get
sixty point one so 6.0.6000.16386 t
point one so this is times ten this is
times ten again I'm essentially
multiplied it by 100 but now we have it
in the form we like we have 60 point one
over 100 or you can rewrite this this is
the same thing as 60 point one
/ / hundred per hundred which is the
same thing as 60 point one per cent and
we'd obviously want to write then as
60.1% as one word or sixty point one and
we'll just use the symbol 60.1% we are
done